[Music]
okay so it's very
important I'm going to introduce a drill
you're going to Asser it that's just
what happens then I take out whatever
part you did not assert and I work from
there okay that's that's the upic way so
for example those people uh work in the
cooku set it's fine as I said
externally that you are bracing and
pushing on the center okay that's all we
got but we can work from there doesn't
mean it's right so as you keep working
the drill you have to keep refining the
drill concentrate on the pointers I gave
you so for example it's not that they
get displaced it is how you displace
them so don't measure your success
assessed by whether they moved or not or
when I go ahead and say you know what
really just focus in on drill one and
release while maintaining positional
integrity that's going to get you
further than if you're just displacing
them externally or as I tell you at a
certain point don't do the other drills
do the last drill where you don't have
the bracing angle okay and you that's me
working from where you're
at so in this next drill that we use and
uh for example Ivan I think you ought to
start heading here continue to work with
your feet together uh when you work the
C you set and then play with this drill
okay uh and so the takeaway here is that
the coke you set is the beginner drill
just to get you in the ballp part it's
not the end all drill okay this this is
now going to start working on things
that they're kind of in the coke you
drill set but not overtly this is
overtly okay and you probably aren't
ready for this because you probably
assured the cooku drill set and this
will help refine that uration okay so in
this game he pushes at me and I and I
project okay that's you've seen us do
this several times we don't worry about
the throw we just work on the projection
part okay so what happens is as we have
here we have some people
that can do the CQ drill set and then
when they get to
this they can't do this drill so there's
two ways that this tends to manifest the
incorrect way which I'll demonstrate now
and what we want out of it the correct
way so the incorrect way is you move out
of the way and then you push
that with any number of ways that you do
that
okay that's not going to help us because
that that could happen in altercation or
it could happen uh but it's not what we
try to do so for example in K Anda
that's not correct we don't do that in
KIU Anda okay what we do instead is we
deviate in a way to load the arm that he
ends up bouncing off of okay so I'll
work with this right hand here I am
doing the incorrect way I get out of the
way and then I push it it doesn't matter
whether your hands are not uh going out
so for example don't get focused on this
version my hands going out this version
is also wrong my hands don't go out and
that version is also wrong because the
energy is not being internalized and
increasingly uh G generating the CQ that
I'm going to project with okay so it
doesn't really matter what my hands are
doing it matters what I'm doing in my
deviation again doesn't matter on the
handshake but him coming in is loading
what gets deflected okay so we're going
to work on that and I'll film them as
they're working on it you'll see who's
able to do it who's not they get to see
themselves on video but that is what
you're trying to do in this this drill
load the cou hand with their assault not
get out of the way and then attack okay
he keep going I'll tell you when this
stop
you're going to keep going I'm going to
talk okay out of the way
push out of the way
push out of the way a little
better out of the way a little better
there we
go better okay what did you have to do
differently let more pressure build up
yes let more pressure build up so pay
attention to your angle deviation okay
in regards to I need to let more
pressure build up so do the first way
and watch your angle of deviation and
note what it is the first wrong
way okay do it again same side because
you're going to describe to me what
you're doing doing terms of geometry
he okay what are you
doing I'm deviating yeah you're getting
out of the way I know that that's why
it's called angle
deviation um I'm just basically getting
to a point where I feel zero
pressure um I think I'm deviating
90° let's watch and let's just just see
if that's true same
thing what else can you tell me it's not
90° no it isn't it's um it's kind of in
front of him maybe 135 45 degrees I
mean all right you're going like to 5
4:30
5:30 6:30
7:30 do you understand okay what what is
happening you said zero pressure okay so
I'm moving ahead of him let's check for
zero pressure so we know it wasn't 90 de
and you're going to check for zero
pressure
he so zero pressure is a phrase I use
okay you're going to get a t-shirt
slogan you're going to start using my
phrase but you don't have the same
definition okay so zero pressure is
what zero pressure is when You'
when you're not pushing or
pulling against
UK what's zero pressure
Andrew so you're neither above nor below
your uh your ukase pressure got got that
okay ne ne never so watch and let's ask
if you go
below do the same
move off
below
push pay
attention below
push so it's not zero pressure okay so a
couple
things there's one more thing but I
don't think you'll ever get it which
it's related to zero pressure so when
you move to the
angle you let him by that's say it's not
zero pressure
you see pay
attention here Z pressure is here you
see you go here you're now negative and
that's why you can push okay so if we
look at the third thing that I want you
to
notice is his Center gravity and the
majority of his
weight passes your projection point you
see that and that's why you have to go
positive
at this point in the video I'll put the
corrections that you did okay but you're
going to see that you didn't let his
Center gravity pass the projection
point you took enough deviation to get
it and you hit it at a at an angle do
you see that of course you could go
straight back in but we want that spiral
rotation and that's where I project
there not let you go past cuz now I'm
doing the second thing you see that so
in your phrase when you said let more
pressure yeah okay when you let it go
past you you don't have pressure loading
it
anymore so I let pressure build that's
where I
hit
so now let's say
I can't
basee do you understand whoa he's
starting to push me that's not going to
make this
right maybe so for maybe for example on
me you know I can I can do this all on
one leg so I that's all I need to get
this power rotation that'll work to load
you so let's look at the angle you're
coming this way I just need a kind of
shearing angle
that's it that's enough but
maybe you when you take that same angle
because you can't ground maybe you start
to feel
compromised you have some options here
you can change your Tachi so I'll go to
that same shooting angle it's starting
to overpower me I turn
it you see that so I keep the same
shearing angle boom and there'll be less
pressure coming into me because I did
the tesak or I can keep the same Tachi
but instead of being as sharp as I am
here I just take a little off but I
don't let your Center pass me do you
guys see that and then of course you
can't combine the two so I'm over here I
get that whoa I feel I'm going to lose
it so I do K aaki you see but I don't
want you to pass
me I feel overpowered here again then I
take the
step you guys see that but you can't let
this Center go by you entirely he go it
goes by me because I project I project
it off at that angle got it in this case
I'm T taking you back to 10 and two and
that's where I want you to work now
you're 10 and two you're not going to
make this mistake of getting out of the
way and not loading okay so for now work
T in two okay here we go
[Music]
okay so that one where she got kind of
jacked up that that one was telling in
the gross fashion but the the errors
that led to that one they're in all of
what you're doing so go back and
diagnose what happened in the gross eror
one what what happened just describe
what
happened uh I think I was searching for
something no no describe what was the
gross
air what' she do what happened to her
body pressed in on you too much yeah C
she kind of kind of closed right okay so
in order for her to press in too much
what's that telling you that I'm not
deviating enough
no cuz then we'll get into that other
problem how' she get
past where you wanted her to be is
another way of saying that question how
did she get past where you wanted her to
be
I'm not okay so anyone want to take a
guess at it it's just a logical question
how did she get
past you know penetration how did she
penetrate past what you wanted her to
penetrate that's the
question what do you got either he went
negative on the pressure or his
architecture collapsed under her y uh
who can do better
let her yeah I know you let her but how
did it happen it wasn't that you brought
your hands in cuz then you wouldn't
experience too far if you brought your
hands in she would have came in where
your hands went your hands stayed here
she got past that do do you get that do
you understand this okay so it's
probably not what you're saying it's
something
else there wasn't an adhesion in no no
cuz the adhesion is not really going to
keep you in or out in this regard
there's something
else all right let's
look we do it one here okay come
forward come forward come
forward come forward
come forward come forward come forward
I'm over here weirdo here's forward come
forward why is she comeing
forward because her arm was independed
of her Center open the door what open
the door you you can put your arm any
anywhere I'll put it I'll put it uh
around your right hip just keep coming
forward here I don't know what you're
doing aim right there with your
CBE did that look hard for me no okay uh
aim over at at at
Taylor aim right over my
shoulder what's going on never
where does the CQ line go where does it
go anywhere the center but where should
it go in the center do you see that so
when you come around here and you're
you're outside her Center then she just
walks in she's just going to walk in you
get it so wherever your hand even even
if I go got it got it okay
push
push do you see I'm not I'm not at her
Center but
obviously I have her
Center I have her Center do you see that
so wherever your hands are this is goes
back to the last video video wherever
your hands are they're on the
center do do you got that so no matter
how they move even if I'm trying to load
she can't push cuz I have the center do
you get that what you did is not have
her Center she walked in okay your hands
woren in that b place it's not as gross
a mistake as out here but you could see
even from out here boom you can still
hit the center from there so just
remember that as you're loading I'm
going to talk so go really slow as
you're loading don't go
negative do you see that yes load but
it's not this is not disconnected from
her center it's on her Center and I'm
just letting it go through
me okay try it
again stay in the center
keep going I'll tell you
when even as you're coming back and
you're increasing pressure stay in the
center that's
better
okay uh now
now you're making the mistake from the
last
video you're like stay in the
center stay in the
center stay in the center you don't have
to you don't need the 180 line on there
so you can't advance that way okay so in
the last video what I said is from here
where wherever she's touching me her
forces I have to consciously feel what
well that's going to go over her
shoulder do you see I have to put this
into her
Center so I'll tell you what I feel try
not to change anything for me okay so I
feel like okay I'm going to
go down you see that there there I'm I'm
taking the pressure and I'm making it go
down and as I do that I feel that she's
rolling forward on me so I have to
change it and I start to spill over the
top if she drops the elbow it starts to
come off so I start to turn it do you
see and then you got her so all this is
on the Fly you feel what she's doing you
want to be in the center I got to get in
the center so if I go down there's
nothing there so I have to work this
whole thing motion see how I came back a
little to bring more weight onto it
that'll change the angle that I need
there's your center right
there do you get what I'm saying yes I
don't have to go Center okay all right
let's try it
okay pay attention to what he's doing it
is right but you guys that are not at
his level are not doing this and this
is you're going to
see that he starts the projection and
people always react always react to it
they they just do okay again to make
yourself
improve don't react to
it so what I mean is this was my
singular
intention I keep katate I drive he goes
and I keep
it you won't see me go here you see that
that's a
reaction he didn't do that his hands are
going that way in space there's no way
my hands should come back you get it so
or as he goes and he starts to project
you feel this you went like that you see
that that's what was happening a lot to
Taylor as you guys were going you come
here and instead of just keeping
pressure that you
had you're going into this
thing you see that okay so pay attention
you'll feel that pressure that's where
you should have just stayed where you
were but as the pressure was going in
you you absorbed it and you kept coming
forward you see that
now St there there's really no pressure
here if you pay attention he h he does
this little hand
flatter you see that that's how he's
staying in the center regardless if the
hand is up that high so you'll see he's
not he's not doing what a lot of you are
doing because you pick beforehand you
pick beforehand and you go you paid
attention energy came off pay attention
on the right hand I go here energy comes
off there especially as you bend your
arms okay bend your arms yes you
see so you'll see him refine your Center
boom do you see that so he absorbed
again but that's telling you the
pressure was in him how did you reabsorb
again on the second one I think I lower
you let go your grip open so you'll do
it again here it is you'll feel it
coming in and you see you let go right
you see that so he lets go and you have
to still feel this what the next point
is okay but that'll make
you only be a good training tool for him
you're now not
training because if you go back and you
look at why you're doing all of this
stuff it's because you're afraid as
redefine fear and you can't accept
what's happening to you so
good on him he's doing it
right good that you are effing up and
now he has a harder drill but not good
for you okay so you keep this
relationship and you come in and that's
all you
do this is all you do every
time you know aren going to go
here or any variation of that
that I
like you see
that I was already running that way do
you understand I just hear and you
go now he gets on his feedback
now he feels like he got it but I did
not be a
good he's not really seeing what's
happening okay try it again so if we go
to a Kean it's going to be the same he's
driving I take enough deviation that I
can load that
hand got it there's a there's some
difference now because I'm not just
trying to move him in the sagittal plane
I'm trying to generate that front inward
kazushi okay so as I get into the center
I hit there and as he starts to bounce
off that's when I turn back into the arm
cuz that's when the arm becomes
isolated you don't want to come into the
arm at the
start he he hits boom Center you get it
then you continue this the spiral don't
go negative
and then attempt to push that that is
something different got it you know what
causes that what you let him go
completely by you and then you
push and to me the first EDD me is the
end of the technique because after that
requires a what if what if he keeps
pushing on the arm well then I come
around I keep attacking the arm okay so
deviate as much as your skills require
hit the center and continue the
spiral into the
Ed if you projecting correctly you don't
get pinned when you're making him go
away from you so once he
deviates Bo moving in do you see I can
move in in right
[Music]
away again it doesn't matter if you're
low low doesn't matter if you're high
you can touch the center from wherever
you're at high arm touch the
center low arm T the center I can go
below the
[Music]
center got
it you're in keyho now so the ritual has
to do both yin and you can't just be the
Y okay so when you
get you can't go
here you have to come into the yin
fit see that I have to undo that got
it so I'm here full and I'm coming here
around you see feel that feel that push
I go around
it so it's going to
go no yeah I know you could do that but
it's not iido you have to go y around
that it goes this
way around you
this
way so pay
attention to this part I do one more
Circle one more circle now it's off now
I just leave
then I catch
it do you
see don't go y project y penetrate okay
all right a detail on the on the
technique so the order of sequence after
you get them
projected is off the Y Line catch the
elbow the elbow pushes the grip into
this
hand do the same side you got your
projection okay there's that young line
come around
it elbow elbow pushes the grip that's
when you catch the grip do not go here
there boom off the Y Line catch the
elbow that's what gets it in your
grip okay clear the Y Line push the
elbow that's what takes it off your grip
do not reach
across hand off now you get the elbow
that's the wrong order sequence okay